he's a spiritual leader and founder of
the Art of Living Foundation The Art of
Living Foundation aims to relieve
individual stress societal problems and
violence in 1997 he established the
International Association for human
values
he's Sri Sri Ravi Shankar and here are
his top ten rules for success
I am one who always welcomes criticism I
and I encourage people you should
welcome criticism and we board enough to
give criticism if the criticism is
coming out of benevolence that I want
that someone is criticizing so that I
can become better then it is always
welcome but if someone is criticizing
just out of jealousy are trying to pull
someone down then that is not good then
that is coming from him malefic mindset
so constructive criticism I feel
everyone should welcome criticism with
compassion criticism with love he is the
most adorable thing and it should always
be welcomed if you can M embrace the
Embera has meant nothing can shake you
it's one thing that people try to run
away from is embarrassment yeah
criticism a mild form of embarrassment
is a mild form of criticisms a mild form
of feeling and uncomfortable
so sometimes we need to get out of the
comfort zone feel that little
uncomfortable less then you know
abilities in a storm
if you are content happy if you are
centered
everything will flow to you you don't
have to go and grab something things
have come your way do you see what I'm
saying this is this is why this world is
called Maya you know why am i I mean
when you try to go and grab it it runs
away from you what if we try to possess
if you're trying to grab something it
just runs away and if you are stable
still content within yourself
they all run towards you you know I say
we are all global people we have to
learn something from everywhere in the
world and I would say we have to learn
the precision and the timeliness and the
commitment from Germans the world should
learn I always say the perfection is
always Germans they ticka sees is always
from England
the mannerism maitika sees you know and
business and salesmanship Americans sell
teamwork from Japanese Japanese are so
good in teamwork
similarly spirituality from India human
values spirituality compassion it all
comes from India so we need to get the
best from every part of the world and
the next coming generation will see that
sort of global human being you know of
course technology has shrunk the whole
world into a global village today
through technology in one second we
communicate with the whole world in the
same way if we can tune our minds to
that simplicity the innocence to caring
and sharing we will find the whole world
as one family the global family when you
want to have balance you will definitely
have it you can
it know what it just this I want to have
balance my life this thought it's always
good enough you have already balancing
you are moving in the direction yeah
this question simply arises how do I do
it you know you can do it
ask yourself your consciousness will
tell you I am NOT balanced I am missing
out on this your consciousness will say
then you listen to your consciousness if
you are attending to your work too much
your consciousness will prick he you are
forgetting your family your wife your
children your husband then you say okay
how I attend to them if you are
attending too much immersed so much in
the family and forget about all other
things then your consciousness will
prick my god what am I got into what did
they get into their net I am just
immersed in this family affairs I am NOT
being useful to the world I had to do
something add to pursue my cause I had
to do justice to my work look my dear
prick then you do that but this wanting
to keep balance in life that very
thought is good enough it's like the
fuse in the electrical system you know
you know the fuse in the electrical
system whenever the electric current
surges too much the fuse will break and
saved everything else like that that
little amount of guilt must be there
like the fuse in the system
you don't justify your what but that
little bit is okay to have like the fuse
in it
Electric you know about the electrical
system you need all that electrical
board there will be one small box called
fuse so whenever there is imbalance in
current the fuse will burst and save the
rest of the
electrical system like that in life a
little bit of Gilson is okay but not too
much like salt in the food if there is
too much salt can you eat it no got it
so wanting to her balance is good to
have them like breathing in and
breathing out we need passion we need
dispassion and we need compassion all
three has to exist people without
passion cannot achieve anything in their
life so you need passion especially
youngsters they need to have a passion
they lack passion they get into
depression
so passion is essential but only passion
this has been the problem only passion
will lead to disappointment and despair
so you need to have little detachment
that is dispatchable and this passion is
where it's like okay you did lot of
activity and you take some time to sleep
rest you let everything go and you relax
you switch over to the side and
meditation is part of the ability to let
go and move forward that I would call as
dispassion and in between we need
compassion if you see you have made a
wrong decision you have to weigh the
pros and cons should I continue on this
all my life
or should I change if I change what is
the loss that I will face what is the
problems I may encounter you have to
weigh it you have to see how much the
change will make you better or if the
change is going to make even more
problematic better don't change just
carry on with whatever you are wrong
decision you made you know sometimes you
can't change you have made a wrong
decision you have to go
you know you can't think of being a
bachelor after you have had a kid once
you have a child then you have to be a
father or mother and continue there no
point in regretting the past similarly
he wanted to be a doctor but you became
an engineer and after 25 years of
serving as an engineer you can't say no
I made a wrong choice I should have been
a doctor there's no point now you can't
go back to to study in the school and
become a doctor again you are an
engineer continuing that dad got it so
you have to weigh the pros and cons you
see to achieve anything in the world it
needs effort to achieve anything in the
world any pleasure or any material thing
you want to achieve
it needs effort if you look at the
benefits that meditation bring into our
life we feel it is all the more relevant
all the more needed in ancient times
meditation was used for enlightenment
for to finding the self and meditation
is a way to get rid of misery to
overcome misery herkim problems
meditation has been the way to improve
one's abilities three things and today
living apart living aside enlightenment
if you see the social ills of today the
stress and tension it calls for one to
meditate the more responsibility you
have in your life
more is the need for meditation the life
is much larger than failure and success
life is much larger than birth then
death we are much beyond them or not it
if you have this strength if you can
understand this knowledge then you will
walk like a king
nobody can shake you thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Shagun Rawat asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of the top 10
rules had the biggest impact on you
leave it in the comments and I will join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon